So three and a half weeks ago I did a story
for you guys called.
Dr. Foushee has been disappeared from Trump's
briefings.
That was nearly a full months ago.
And at the time we were seeing signals of
what was to come get the doctors the hell
out of the way.
Stop talking about death.
Stop talking about masks and people doing
the stuff that they need to do.
Simply start talking about reopening.
And this is when I told you back three and
a half weeks ago that Trump was no longer
going to have doctors at briefings.
He would be shifting away from daily medical
briefings where media get to talk to doctors
like Dr. Foushee and Dr. Burke's.
They're just going to talk about the economy.
It's gonna be like the disease is over.
They are going to normalize the corona virus
deaths.
Not only did that happen.
Dr. Foushee has been disappeared from an interviews
on television as well.
He has not been seen since.
I believe it was May 4th.
There was a while where Dr. Foushee was pulled
off of Trump's briefings, but he was still
doing regular television interviews.
No more.
Foushee has been conspicuously absent from
TV for more than two weeks now.
It is completely, utterly, obviously clear
that this is part of a concerted effort to
make it seem like the virus part of the pandemic
is over.
Now, of course, you know, this isn't true.
We fortunately started to see sort of a slow
decline in new cases.
And that's, of course, very good.
Deaths have been kind of up and down if you
look at a moving average, as we call it.
They've also been on a decline.
That's all really, really good news.
But this is still a pandemic.
We still have no effective treatment.
We are still months from a vaccine.
We are still shut down in a significant portion
of state economies.
But the doctors are gone.
You just don't see them anymore.
Dr. Fouty's last TV interview, again, I believe,
was May 4th.
That's two and a half weeks ago.
He's been missing since.
And I need you to understand that this is
not a coincidence.
He is missing not because nobody wants to
interview him anymore.
Media want to talk to Dr. Foushee.
He's been pulled.
Now, some of you might wonder, wasn't Foushee
on a modified quarantine after he was exposed
to people at the White House who tested positive
for Corona virus?
That shouldn't stop him from doing interviews.
Dr. Foushee was regularly doing interviews
by videoconference before he testified before
the Senate via video conference.
That is not the reason why Dr. Foushee is
no longer on TV.
If there was ever a week to have Dr. Foushee
on TV, it would be dead this week.
Good results from a vaccine trial.
He works for the NIH, which is working in
partnership with these private industry, private
companies developing a corona virus vaccine.
This is just short of North Korean style propaganda.
We've got a 100 year global pandemic that's
ravaging the economy, our economy and the
global economy.
Obviously, you put food CEOs on TV instead
of an infectious disease doctor.
And the other night on CNN, they said we are
no longer going to be allowed to interview
Dr. Foushee and Dr. Burke's.
The White House is no longer allowing them
to do interviews on CNN anymore.
Now, you could say, well, CNN is fake news.
Obviously, they're not going to be fair.
Well, they're not being allowed to do interviews
anywhere.
And this is such a common technique.
It's called Hide the facts.
There's an article from earlier this month
in The Guardian from economist Robert Reich,
and he wrote about Trump's four step plan
to reopen the United States.
And the forced steps are start removing income
support so people have no choice but to return
to work.
One twelve hundred dollar check.
Unclear that there's going to be another check
at this point in time.
Check.
They're doing it.
No.
To hide the facts.
And that's what we're talking about today.
That's where Dr. Foushee fits in.
This is where Florida not releasing cause
of death fits in.
Hide the facts.
Number three, pretend that it's all about
freedom and patriotism and liberty.
They're doing that.
And then number four, Robert Reich wrote about
this nearly a month ago.
Shield businesses from lawsuits for spreading
the infection by opening too early.
All week.
Donald Trump has been talking about how he
wants to see that made a reality.
We're a backwards country.
We need to be hearing more from doctors, not
less.
We do not need to be hearing from Fast-Food
CEOs. Trump did.
I covered it live and I.
It was disgusting.
Trump did a whole roundtable earlier this
week with restaurant people, and they also
found a psychiatrist willing to say, we've
got to reopen the economy.
Now that that's an entire other story, they
have now been looking for random doctors willing
to say.
My medical opinion is we should open her,
open her up and let it rip.
They did find one earlier this week, but they're
hiding the truths, the truth.
They are hiding Dr. Foushee, and instead they're
bringing, you know, the the CEO of a chicken
joint to talk about how important it is that
we get back open.
It is ugly and it is bordering on the type
of propaganda that typically we see from totalitarian
countries.
Places where you have a real authoritarian
trumps a want to be authoritarian.
He is very quickly becoming a real one.
That includes hiding the facts here.
Later on, we will talk about Donald Trump's
threats to states over vote by mail plans.
Really, really ugly, dangerous stuff.
We'll continue covering this and other stories
from today's program on The David Pakman Show
Instagram.
Follow us at David Pakman show on Instagram
and follow me at David.
Got packed.
Don't forget about little old me.